[Music]
before we move on to understanding acids
bases and salts in detail we can quickly
recap what we already know about them
the word acids thanks Kerry right it
comes from the Latin word a siddhis
which means sour yes most acids taste
sour lemons for instance have acid and
you surely know how lemons taste and
we've also seen that acids turn blue
litmus paper red based on the recurrence
they are divided into two types natural
acids and mineral acids as the name
suggests natural acids are obtained from
natural sources they're also called as
organic acids citric acid which we get
from citrus fruits is an organic acid
mineral acids on the other hand are
assets that are prepared using minerals
they are also known as man-made assets
or inorganic acids nitric acid is an
example of mineral acid what about basis
you can think of them as being opposite
to acids they are bitter in taste and
turn red litmus paper blue sodium
carbonate and lime are examples of bases
what are salts there is common salt
assault what are the chemical properties
of acids and bases how do they react
with metals how do they react with each
other
is there any scale which helps us
understand if a substance is an acid or
a base
Hansa do all these questions and much
more in the coming videos happy learning
[Music]